pourquoi tes doigts crack tout le monde
te dit de ne pas le faire que c'est
dangereux est-ce vrai ou faux ça c'est
ce qui se passe quand tu te craque une
articulation en blanc c'était zoo entre
les deux c'est du liquide synovial un
lubrifiant quand tu tires l'espace entre
tes doigts augmente la pression du
liquide baisse ça crée des bulles de CO2
qui éclatent immédiatement c'est ça le
pop ça prend environ 20 minutes pour que
toutes les bulles aient disparu et que
tu puisses te craquer à nouveau pour les
coudes ou les genoux quand tu te lèves
trop vite le bruit que tu entends vient
plutôt de tes tendons qui s'étire contre
les eaux pour tester les risques un
chercheur a fait craquer les doigts de
sa main gauche pendant 50 ans un
demi-siècle de pop aucun signe
d'arthrite ou d'arthrose avec modération
aucun danger mais si ça devient un TOC à
la longue ça peut amener des tendinites
ou inflammation des mains de temps en
temps oui mais tout le temps non
maintenant tu sais